so I thought something I'm slightly
embarrassed to admit to and at the age
of 17 as a creationist I decided to go
to university to study evolution so that
I could destroy it I failed I failed so
spectacularly but I'm now an
evolutionary biologist so so I'm a
paleoanthropologist I'm a National
Geographic Explorer specializing in
fossil hunting in caves in unstable
hostile and disputed territories and we
all know so if I was a guy and not a
girl that wouldn't be a job description
that would be a pick-up line now here's
the thing I do not have a death wish
I'm not an adrenaline junkie I just
looked at a map see frontline
exploratory science does not happen as
much in politically unstable territories
this is a map of all the places which
the British Foreign Office have declared
contain red zones orange zones or have
raised some kind of a threat warning
about now I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and say that it is a tragedy if
we're not doing frontline exploratory
science in a huge portion of the planet
and so science science has a geography
problem also as a paleoanthropologist
guys this is basically a map of some of
the most important places in the human
journey there are almost definitely
fascinating fossils to be found here but
are we looking for them and so as an
undergraduate I was repeatedly told that
humans be there ourselves Homo sapiens
or earlier species that we left Africa
by the sinai of Egypt I'm English as you
can probably tell from my accent but I'm
actually of Arab heritage and I always
say that I'm very very Arab on the
outside you know Mike I'm really really
passionate like you're amazing I love
you but on the inside I'm really
everybody irritates me it's true and the
thing is my family are Arab from Yemen
and I knew that that channel burbled men
dub is not that much of a feat to cross
and I kept asking myself this really
simple question if the ancestors to new
world monkeys could somehow cross the
Atlantic Ocean
why couldn't humans cross that tiny
stretch of water but the thing is Yemen
compared to let's say Europe were so
understudied but it was something akin
to near virgin territory but that along
with its location made the sheer
potential for discovery so exciting and
I had so many questions when did we
first start using bab-el-mandeb
but also which species of human beside
ourselves made it to Yemen might we find
a species as yet unknown to science and
it turned out I wasn't the only one who
would notice Yemen's potential there was
actually a few other academics out there
and but sadly due to political
instability they moved out and so I
moved in and I was looking for caves
caves because caves are the original
prime real estate but also because if
you're looking for fossils in that kind
of heat your best bet for fossil
preservation is always gonna be caves
but then Yemen took a really sad turn
for the worst and just a few days before
I was due to fly out to Yemen the civil
war escalated into a regional conflict
the Capitals airport was bombed and
Yemen became a no-fly zone now my
parents made this decision before I was
born but I would be born British I had
nothing to do with the best decision of
my life and now now the four lucky ones
in my family
State and the others the others are
being bombed and sent to you whatsapp
messages that make you detest your very
existence this war has been going on for
four years it's been going on for over
four years and it is led to a
humanitarian crisis there is a famine
there a man-made famine that's a
man-made from it's not a natural famine
an entirely man-made famine that the UN
has warned could be the worst famine the
world has seen in a hundred years
this war has made it clear to me more
than ever that no no place no people
deserve to get left behind and so I was
I was joining these other teams and I
was forming new collaborations and other
unstable places but I was desperate to
get back into Yemen because for me
Yemen's really personal and so I kept
trying to think of a project I could do
in Yemen that would help highlight what
was going on there and every idea I had
just kept failing or it was just too
high-risk because let's be honest most
of Yemen is just too dangerous for a
Western team but then I was told that
socotra a Yemeni island was safe once
you got there in fact it turned out
there was a few local and international
academics that were still working there
and that got me really excited because
look at sakata's proximity to Africa and
yet we have no idea when humans arrived
on that island
but socotra for those of you who know it
well let's just say you probably know it
for a completely different reason you
probably know it as the Galapagos of the
Indian Ocean because it is one of the
most biodiverse places on this earth but
we were also getting information but
this incredibly delicate environment and
its people were under threat
because they were at the front line of
both Middle Eastern politics and climate
change and it slowly dawned on me that
socotra was my Yemen project and so I
wanted to put together a huge
multidisciplinary team we wanted to
cross the archipelago on foot camel and
Dow boat to conduct a health check of
this place this has only been attempted
once before and it was in 1999 but the
thing is that is not an easy thing to
pull off
and so we desperately needed a recce and
for those of you who aren't familiar
with British English a recce is like a
scouting expedition it's like a
reconnaissance and and I often say that
a really big expedition without a recce
is a bit like a first date without a
Facebook stalk like it's doable but is
it wise
there's a few too many knowing laughs in
this room anyway so so then our recce
team thankfully were no strangers to
unstable places let's be honest it's
kind of important because we were trying
to get to a place between Yemen and
Somalia and after calling in what felt
like a million favors including to the
deputy governor we finally found
ourselves on the move albeit on a wooden
cement cargo ship sailing through pirate
waters in the Indian Ocean with this as
a toilet can you guys see this you know
you know how everybody has their worst
toilet story well I have never swam with
dolphins before I just went straight to
pooping on them so and also I genuinely
discovered that I am genuinely less
stressed by pirate waters than I am with
a cockroach infestation that was so
intense that at one point I went below
deck and the floor was black and it was
moving yeah and at night there was there
was three raised platforms to sleep on
but there was only well let's say
there's four team members and I think is
if you've got a raised platform to sleep
on you only have to contend with a few
cockroaches during the night or as if
you got the floor good luck to you and
and so I was the only girl in the team
and the home ship so I got away without
sleeping on the floor and then on like
the fourth or fifth night Martin
Hedstrom looks at me and goes Ella and I
really believe in equality
so we were sailing on that cement cargo
ship for three days and then we slowly
started seeing land and after three
years of failing I was finally seeing
Yemen and there is no feeling on earth
like that start of an expedition it's
this moment where you jump out of a jeep
or you look up from a boat and you know
that there's this possibility it's small
but it's still there that you're about
to find something that could add to or
change your knowledge of who we are and
where we come from there is no feeling
like it on earth and it's a feeling that
so many scientists have but rarely in
politically unstable places because
Western scientists are discouraged tore
all out barred from war working in
unstable places but here's the thing
scientists scientists specialize in the
jungle scientists work in deep cave deep
cave systems scientists attach
themselves to rockets and blow
themselves into outer space but
apparently working in an unstable place
is deemed too high-risk
it is completely arbitrary who here in
this room wasn't for up on adventure
stories and most of our heroes were
actually scientists and academics
science was about going out into the
unknown it was about truly global
exploration even if there were risks and
so when did it become acceptable to make
it difficult for science to happen in
unstable places and look I'm not saying
that all scientists should go off and
start working in unstable places this
isn't some gung-ho call but here's the
thing for those who have done the
research understand security protocol
and a trained stop stopping those who
want to Plus look just because one part
of a country is an
active war zone doesn't mean the whole
country is I'm not saying we should go
into active war zones but Iraqi
Kurdistan looks very different fruit
Fallujah and actually a few months after
I couldn't get into Yemen another team
adopted me so professor Graham barça's
team were actually working in Iraqi
Kurdistan and they were digging up
shanidar cave now shanidar cave a few
decades earlier had unveiled and the and
earth all known as shanidar one now for
a BBC PBS TV series we actually brought
shanidar one to life and i want you guys
to meet Ned Ned the Neanderthal now he's
the coolest thing about Ned Ned this guy
you're meeting him before his injuries
see it turned out that Ned was severely
disabled he was in fact so disabled that
there is no way that he could have
survived without the help of other
Neanderthals and so this was proof that
at least for this population of
Neanderthals at this time
Neanderthals were like us and they
sometimes looked after those who
couldn't look after themselves but Ned's
Ned's an Iraqi Neanderthal so what else
are we missing what incredible
scientific discoveries are we not making
because we're not looking and by the way
these places they deserve narratives of
hope and science and exploration can be
a part of that in fact I would argue
that it can tangibly aid development and
these discoveries become a huge source
of local pride and that brings me to the
second reason why science has a
geography problem see we don't empower
local academics do we like it's not lost
on me that in my particular field of
paleoanthropology
we study human origins but we have so
few diverse scientists and the thing is
these places are full of students and
academics who are desperate to
collaborate and the truth
is that for them they have fewer
security issues than us I think we
constantly forget that for them it's not
a hostile environment for them it's home
I'm telling you research done in
unstable places with local collaborators
can lead to incredible discoveries and
that is what we are hoping upon hope to
do in socotra they call socotra the most
alien looking place on earth and myself
Leon McCarran Martin Hedstrom Andrew
straits Jones could see why I mean look
at this place
these places they're not hell holes
they're not write-offs they're the
future frontline of science and
exploration 90% of the reptiles on this
island 37% of the plant species exist
here and nowhere else on earth and that
includes this species of dragons blood
tree which actually bleeds this this red
resin and there's something else people
on socotra some of them still live in
caves and that is really exciting
because it means if a cave is prime real
estate this century maybe it was a few
thousand years ago but we need the data
to prove it the fossils the stone tools
and so our scouting team have teamed up
with other scientists anthropologists
and storytellers international as well
as local like I'm Lara Bobby and we are
desperate to shed a light on this place
before it's too late
and now now we just somehow need to get
back for that really big expedition
because science science has a geography
problem you guys have been a really
lovely audience thank you
[Applause]
[Music]